we've got a big problem on our hands
with global warming a lot of you a lot
of people have been watching the fudge
the droughts the storms the fires when I
leave this stage today I don't want you
to have hope I want you to have
certainty real certainty that we can
make a dent in this problem and live to
see it I want to give you a vision of
what that would look like this is the
first time we've shared this publicly
you're the first audience to hear it we
are going to launch a rocket and on that
rocket will be a satellite and that
satellite will collect data about
pollution that is warming the planet
we'll put that data in the hands of
people who can do make simple fixes that
will change the course of global warming
in our lifetime
that's a lot to take in
maybe I should back up first let me
introduce myself I'm Fred I've been an
environmentalist since I was a kid when
I watched the fish and the frogs in my
neighborhood pond died from a chemical
spill that bothered me later a professor
inspired me to think about
environmentalism differently how the
best solutions come from answering
people's aspirations for Prosperity
things like being safe and healthy and
thriving in this world so I joined the
Environmental Defense Fund to build
those kind of solutions and I've worked
my whole career for a moment like this
the moment when we can stop fighting
headwinds and start to have the wind at
our backs because of the power of
information information from technology
that is coming down in price and going
up in precision
you see there's something about climate
change that we didn't grasp just a
decade ago the world was so focused on
carbon dioxide that we overlooked
another important gas we didn't
appreciate methane methane pollution
causes one quarter of the global warming
that we're experiencing right now
pound for pound its immediate impact is
far greater than carbon dioxide 84 times
greater over a 20-year period one of the
largest sources of methane pollution is
the oil and gas industry but that's not
obvious because methane is invisible
let's take a look at this natural gas
storage facility outside of Los Angeles
can you see the methane neither can I
how about now we shot this using an
infrared camera at the same spot
exposing one of the worst methane leaks
in the history of the United States
that's a very different picture it turns
out that natural gas is displacing our
dependence on coal which emits far more
carbon dioxide but natural gas is mostly
methane so as its produced in processed
and transported to homes and businesses
across America it escapes from wells and
pipes and other equipment it gets up
into the sky and contributes to the
disasters that were now experiencing
that does not have to happen but nobody
had paid much attention to it until we
launched a nationwide study to
understand the problem we use drones
planes helicopters even Google Street
View cars it turns out there's far more
of this methane pollution what then what
the government is reporting it also
turns out that when we find where the
gas is being vented and leaked most of
those sources can be fixed easily and
inexpensively
saving the gas that would have otherwise
been wasted and finally we learned that
when you put information like that into
people's hands they act reading
companies replaced valves and tightened
loose fitting pipes Colorado became the
first state in the nation to limit
methane pollution California followed
suit and the public joined in stweet
started flying hashtag cut methane and
everybody's paying more attention now
we're doing this because we can't wait
for Washington especially not now in
fact we have to take what we've done so
far and go higher to the sky the United
States represents about 10% of this
pollution to find the rest we have to go
global
remember that rocket I mentioned it will
launch a compact satellite called
methane sat to do what no one has been
able to do until now measure methane
pollution from oil and gas facilities
worldwide with exacting precision it's
data stream will allow us to map that
pollution so that everyone can see it
and then it's all about turning data
into action just as we did in the United
States we've seen that when we present
companies with data many of them will
cut the pollution citizens will be
empowered to take action governments
will tighten the regulations and because
all of our data will be free in public
they'll be transparency we'll all be
able to see how much progress is being
made and where which brings me to our
goal to cut this methane pollution by 45
percent by 2025
that will have the same near-term impact
as shutting down 1300 coal-fired power
plants that's one-third of all the
coal-fired power plants in the world
nothing else can have this sort of
near-term impact at such a low cost the
fact that a single satellite can help us
put the brakes on global warming is
truly remarkable this is our chance to
create change in our lifetimes and we
can do it now thanks to the generous
giving of the audacious project we are
on a path toward liftoff but my time is
running short and I promised you a
vision of what a critical piece of the
solution would look like can you see it
can you see how this satellite leverages
the best of science and data and
technology can you see we're entering a
whole new era of innovation that is
supercharging progress can you see that
it's in our hands we've set an
aggressive goal of three years till
liftoff and when that satellite is ready
we'll have a launch party a literal
launch party so imagine a blue sky day
crowds of people television cameras kids
staring up toward the sky at a thing
that will change their future what an
amazing day that will be what a big
opportunity we have I can't wait thank
you
[Applause]